there's no reason for one guy to have
the power de blasio's got
yep it's just too many people 18 million
people well no the issue is he doesn't
have the power people just give it to
him he's just given ridiculous edict
he's not
given the power to do this the cops just
obey him because they don't know what
else that they want because
their no no it's because the officers
that obey the unconstitutional orders of
de blasio are obsessed with suckling his
teats
so they they they love they hate each
other at the same time
no no no no the officers that follow the
unconstitutional edicts like when when
de blasio painted black lives matter
illegally in the street those cops that
went down to guard it are just
in love with de blasio they're just
doing it and they they love licking his
feet no
arrested de blasio for vandalism right
then and there well he stole taxpayer
money to do it
and then 27 cops came out and they're
like a pandemic during everyone has to
wear a mask and then they're good 27
nypd cops were like the smart thing for
me to do is to obey this man right
instead of saying oh my god that are you
nuts it's like we
we did we bent over back you know why
you know what
yep so this is how they the important
point you brought up is that
the the cops who are screwing with this
bar there was nypd there
but now de blasio's like i'm going to
bring in the sheriff's because the nypd
doesn't want to do it
and i i i'm not saying all cops i'm
saying clearly there are cops in big
cities
run by democrats who don't care and you
know why it's really obvious
everybody lost their jobs honestly the
nypd should arrest the sheriffs
for violating the constitution but
listen listen just do it you have you
have
people cops in new york and they're
going around seeing everyone
destitute like suffering and losing
their money and they're like i have a
job
at least i'm safe yeah and then and then
de blasio's basically like
i want you to oppress people and destroy
their lives the cop goes better them
than me
and so they just give him now put on
this white armor now
a lot of i don't want to say the n word
not the bad n word but the german n word
uh german n word yes national socialist
stormtrooper that's the word i like your
video
but i think i already said nazi on the
show
but i mean there was a lot of nazis i
was just doing it just because they
don't want to be on the other end they
were
i i read that there were jewish nazis
like jewish guards who are like if they
find out so i'll just go along with it
because they were scared yeah
dude and you know what people have been
telling me that because i made a post on
my personal facebook because i talked to
my you know just my staten island
friends and i would say of like
dear law enforcement we bent over back
for you please do not enforce these
orders and they're
and some people are like oh they just
they're just following orders it's not
their fault i'm like that's even worse
that's even worse i'm like they took an
oath to hold the constitution we're the
ones paying them
we're the ones that defended them you
know i want to see de blasio and cuomo
only have the power
that they are given by i guess by the
police no no by the police
it's michael males said this on the show
that all of these
illegal acts all of these
unconstitutional laws are letters to
santa
without the men and women in uniform
willing to enforce against the against
the constitution
yeah you know i'd love to see nypd
walking up to these sheriffs at that bar
max's or whatever and just taking the
like three ny nypd guys grab the sheriff
and
trans behind your back you're under
arrest what needs to happen you don't
live here we live here
these cops live in staten island why
would they let them come to their home
i'll tell you this man could you imagine
these these nypd cops who are either
sitting back and doing nothing
or enforcing this imagine if that was
the caliber of young man we had during
world war ii
they'd be like they'd land on the
beaches of normandy and be like look man
you know
i'm just gonna side with the people who
are here because they're the ones in
power i'm not gonna fight to free people
well we need people to stand up and say
i live here get the
out of my home what we need to do is
publicly
i guess privately fund the good officers
yeah because if they're worried about
their jobs that's illegal crowd funding
but yeah if they're worried about losing
their job and getting their pay cut it's
like hey you know
well let's all build up this [ __ ]
five three if you lose your pension if
you lose this
let's take it out of this fund like
you're good you're securing you're
creating a new police department
creating
a charity fund we could do a global
charity creating our own government
here's what i'm advocating for is what
i'm saying
the police should arrest criminals yep
does that sound does that sound crazy
well if it's a bad law yeah you don't
want them arresting people that are that
are
defined i didn't i didn't say people
defined but i said criminals
crime doesn't make you bad like if it's
a bad law you want to become a criminal
to to fight against them
you're misunderstanding i didn't say
cops should arrest people who break the
law
i said cops should arrest criminals well
if you say everyone has to go out and
punch people and i say i'm not going to
do it then i become a criminal on that
you're reading too much into it for no
reason
i'm saying that what i'm saying is when
the sheriff shows up
and illegally detains someone that's
called kidnapping
and they have no constitutional
authority or statutory authority to do
it just because de blasio said so
it is then incumbent upon nypd to say
you are
under arrest for kidnapping for some
crime yeah i think i think they should
uphold that kind of crime that's literal
crime
it's like moral says they can't do it
and they're doing it anyway they need to
be arrested but if you make a law that
says
that you can't do something you need to
do when you have to become a criminal
we're not talking about made up you just
said police should go arrest criminals
we're not talking about some new law
that was just made because de blasio
didn't pass any laws i'm just saying
crime isn't that
benchmark of whether or not you should
be destroyed i get what both of you guys
are saying
because you're you're saying that
criminality is based on
the laws that were made right yes you
know so like being a criminal
is defined by the law but i get what
you're saying at the same exact time
where de blasio and these sheriffs are
also breaking down the law
the police should go and arrest
criminals yeah and i agree and you're
both right at the scene well they should
arrest those criminals
for that not all criminals what why not
because some laws are bad
and those people shouldn't be criminals
how about this constitutional law
i mean i don't think non-violent drug
offenders should be arrested personally
not marijuana i mean you know just
because you say marijuana is illegal
doesn't mean that you should go arrest
them all it's a bad launch
it is a bad law they should be arrested
they should sue and the law should be
open but it destroys people's lives to
get arrested and waste their time it
puts a mark on i think having an
argument about what you think is morally
correct is not the point the point is
the sheriff's are coming in and breaking
the law i think there's a statutory law
being broken by these sheriffs and by
some nypd
and they're spineless pathetic and
terrified whiny baby cops who won't do
anything about that i agree
but it's dangerous to say cops should
arrest anyone that's breaking the law
that's cops should arrest people because
some laws are not
right so you've got to be careful about
what's encouraging for
yeah but you don't want to go disrupt
everybody then you go to a democrat
court and they like to go for life bro
you can't you can't argue that some cops
have the discretion not to arrest people
breaking the law because then you're
gonna have a cop who who helps and
protects his friends
the law has to be upheld we're a nation
of laws if laws are not enforced then
what do you get in this because i told
him he's lawful good
okay you're neutral good it's a dungeons
dragons thing think about all the
democrats who are like we should we
should decriminalize border crossings
they shouldn't arrest these people
they're broke no they did they literally
committed a crime
and just because you don't agree doesn't
mean i have to live by your rules
if we vote for people and laws are
passed we deal with ramifications of it
if eventually we find out the laws are
bad we change those
marijuana is now slowly being legalized
as people start to realize
and yes trump should pardon non-violent
drug offenders
those who are literally non-violent not
anybody who pled down pleaded down
the point is in new york city when an
nypd cop or a sheriff
breaks the law they need to be or
they'll be able to uphold their
their constitutional oath no that you
get fired for that that's not a crime
i mean who's going to fire them the
mayor's not going to fire well and who's
going to arrest the cops committing
crimes
should be the good cops i don't care who
you are if you're committed to crime you
get arrested okay
and that includes activists who are
protesting peaceful and state all the
time
non-violence of a disobedience is the
best most effective way
to get change it works we've seen it
work at work with civil rights
and riots sour people to your cause but
you get arrested
and you deal with the results of
challenging the system there is a there
is a cost to challenging the system
so should the fbi be the ones that are
arresting cops that are violating the
constitution
the fbi doesn't do that that's a fbi
handles federal
i saw a video online of a cop arrested
and another cop yeah
so yeah right then and there like i
think maybe the cop was doing a little
too much like hitting the guy i don't
know i just saw the quick clip they were
on
they immediately took them and they
arrested them were they both on duty
yeah they're both on duty cops and i
think they
might have been working the same exact
thing let me put it this way if
i'm in new york and some guy walks up to
me and grabs me and throws me to the
ground and pins my arm behind my back
for no reason that's assault and battery
so a cop should come and arrest that
person i don't care what they're wearing
i don't care if they're wearing a badge
now the issue with a cop arresting you
is different because
we as a community bestow authority upon
people under the
the ideal that they're going to be
stopping criminals
now a lot of police forces have
citations and fines and quota systems
and that's all that's all bunk bs for
sure we can argue that
but if if i am doing everything legally
and i'm running my business and some
random guy comes in
and blocks the door and won't let
anybody in or takes my customers
and like detains them kidnaps them takes
them in their car
you gotta arrest that person could you
imagine if someone went to your business
and then just like grabbed the clerk and
threw him in a car and drove off you'd
be like
whoa under no statutory or
constitutional authority
did that person do that i don't care if
they're wrong here's another takeaway
from everything going on right now
where there's no constitutional
enforcement from the federal government
to the states
trump can invoke the insurrection act
because of this now he should have done
this six months
typically in the insurrection act it
says if people's constitutional rights
are being deprived he can send in the
military to protect their rights i think
he should
i mean he's not running for reelection i
was hoping that trump was gonna win
and then immediately do the insurrection
act and arrest cuomo
or s de blasio doesn't even need to
arrest him he could send in the military
to new york and reinstate
people's lives that's what needs that he
should just do that right now
just political willpower yeah trump
could do it yeah that's what america
needs right now
you know it's funny because people are
calling for trump to invoke martial law
and you've got like his most ardent
supporters and the left is saying you
know he can't do that or whatever
we're already under martial law it's
it's not martial law means military law
so not literally but we are under totali
the democrats under there's listen
there's constitutional authority
and there's statutory law statutory law
are things that are passed by
legislative body
constitutional authority is based on
what the constitution of your state or
your or the federal government gives you
under neither of these cuomo wolf
newsome whitmer have done things they're
not allowed to do
and the supreme court has said of the
united states you can't do that see what
they do
okay this executive order has been
destroyed by the supreme court i'll
issue the exact same one now literally
the exact
same like they'll change some words or
use some uh alternate arguments to do
the
sounds it sounds dictatorial despotic
psychotic
and in violation of law and trump could
invoke insurrection act because they
keep doing it the one thing i learned
from all of this
there's a reason why we have the
constitution
and there's a reason why the founding
fathers put the number two in there
i don't like to say it i don't like to
think i don't want it that's that's the
you're you're but
you don't bring it up trump's the
president yes but the problem the
problem isn't what the people are doing
right now they elected trump
they elected trump to solve these
problems and the people who are seizing
who are stomping on the rights of
individuals could be stopped by the
president right now
they can also be stopped by us that's a
whole other conversation i don't want
like that to happen but it just seems
like
that would be at right now this point in
time there seems to be nothing happening
from the federal government or from
trump
and that i mean yeah it's gonna be up to
us they're destroying
economics they're not like stealing
people's children
if the cops were coming in and taking
people's kids in the middle of the night
you'd probably see people
enforcing their their second amendment
and i don't know i don't think so
you don't the james younger kids we're
supposed to put a younger case
a man's son has been essentially taken
from him
and the court's ruled that the child
will undergo gender uh reassignment
therapy
if a father wouldn't rise up in defiance
of the government after his son was
taken in that way
then i really don't see the player
that's slow heating up
republicans we're way we're way more
peaceful than the left if we're
if we were as violent as left none of
this would be happening that's a scary
thing yeah
and you know the lockdown protest
against whitmer from months ago
we had tens of thousands of americans
show up peacefully with guns and what
happened she extended the lockdowns
and people just went that was it then
they went home it's like oh because
republicans we want to do everything
legally in the courts
republicans want to be left alone yeah
we just want to be left alone
i appeal to the president donald please
enforce you think he should invoke the
insurrection i think you should protect
our economy at all costs from these
things
especially great things are going right
now if you're not going to win the
election what do you got to lose
it's kind of crazy that it's it's a slow
boil we're frogs in a pot
the economy is destroyed these these
leftists
have no idea how debt to gdp works how
money printing works
how modern monetary policy works
anything like this
and they advocate for things that make
no sense like deficit spending to pay
for health care it's like all you're
doing is
stripping away the savings of people
like it makes it so that nobody should
save anything ever
but then of course they use that and say
we have no savings we should have
government you know mandated
spending you know and and buying uh of
the resources you need
with these democrat states destroying
the economy we get the 600
coven package that that 900 billion
deal attached to a 2.3 a total of 2.3
billion dollars
uh omnibus spending for ridiculous
things like pakistani gender studies
shows you
the system is corrupt and trump isn't
fixing it
that's it trump trump apparently
submitted a budget request that was
similar to the omnibus so people are
mentioning in the super chat
whether it's true or not what does trump
come out and do what does trump come out
do
he says triple it trump didn't say
reopen the economy now i will not sign
this relief bill until there's a mandate
for the states to rip their economies
and protect small businesses
throw more money at it exactly he said
triple democrats who they said
they said great obliged yeah absolutely
trump
it's kind of being a republican in one
way is kind of a double-edged sword
versus being a democrat
and the democrats worldview of fixing it
they can just come in
and like what the dictators are doing
these governors oh i want this done
up here's an order blink it's done even
though it's unconstitutional it's
tyrannical it's illegal
with republicans on the other hand if
they want to fix something we don't act
like for the most part
we don't act like dictators to get
something done and fix it we don't have
to go this process that process and this
push back and that then you got to play
the game and do all this
whereas if it was a democrat here's a
bill sign it tyrannical
done right legislating what you want i
think about that with gun control like
just saying it's illegal all of a sudden
while people are at home printing their
guns like you can't enforce that lawyer
look like a mockery donald trump vetoed
the ndaa
in it is a as an amendment that would
take away his ability to win
it would curtail his ability to invoke
the insurrection act he would require
the secretary of defense
and himself to sign off and provide
reasonable certification to congress to
approve otherwise he would not be able
to invoke the insurrection act
so if so think about it this way one of
the provisions of the insurrection act
is to enforce the constitutional rights
of the citizens of the state
new york is in violation of that
numerous times blocking people from
going to churches and thing
you know and things of that nature
california is shutting los angeles is
shutting off people's water
and electricity for for exercising their
first amendment right
mitch mcconnell on the 29th is going to
convene the senate
to override trump's veto when that
happens
trump will lose the ability to invoke
the insurrection act
if trump would do it he has five more
days
that's it four more days probably to do
it before they
they override his veto who do you have
to send in the national guard
military or national guard federalized
national guard or the military
i worry that if this sets a precedent
and that gets done and what if biden
comes in wants to ban guns
nationwide no the second amendment that
would be in defiance of
the constitution but so i mean what
we're seeing is these these
police officers don't care right but
with the military
the military i don't think would well i
feel we'll see
you know like yeah i never thought in i
never thought i would see
law enforcement yeah arrest people for
not working i never did
never because i had an experience with
it so not here
that's what they used to say oh never
happened i think the military is not
going to go door to door
they will right before lockdown started
i talked i did an interview with
um an nypd officer and i was telling him
about the whole lockdowns i'm like i was
saying there's no way in hell
that this will ever be enforced and this
is before all this happened and he said
to me
you'll be surprised i did not believe
him i refuse to believe him
and then a month later i've been to
enough countries i've been to enough
protests
and i've seen enough action from police
to know that many of these people just
don't care now i don't think all cops
are bad that you know the left uses a
worse word than that and 1312 or
whatever
acab i think there are a lot of bad cops
and i think we need police reform yep
and i think there are a lot of good cops
and they tend to be smaller cities they
tend to be more rural
and they tend to be conservative and
they know it's the big city cops
who will you know beach over the head
and say i don't care you're right we
need to fund them
the people that are violating the orders
because if they lose their job
that's it you know for them but if we
have a charity that making sure they're
going to get paid regardless
then there's incentive to do the right
thing you should start it tim you've got
no i don't know about that hire someone
to start it
you know people get mad at me because
they think i'm i'm going to be some like
a leader
i'll start it and then i'll pay you to
promote it not sponsorship people people
people like uh trump supporters are mad
saying like everyone's gotta be on the
front lines of this fight and going out
showing up on dc on the six and i'm like
i'm i'm i might i might go to
i don't know i got tired of all these
lockdown protests now this was like
the sixth the six isn't a lockdown
protest the sixth is the
overturning the election for trump
protest so they're saying everyone has
to go there and i'm like bro
i'm not a leader i'm not a part of your
tribe i'm a dude who complains on the
internet
and i will always be there and i'm not
going to rally or rabble or tell anybody
what they should or shouldn't do
i'll tell you what i think what i want
to happen and you do your thing you make
your own opinions his uh
drone war and escalation and his lack of
leadership on assange has really kind of
soured me to donald what's his lack of
leadership on assange he's just not
doing anything about it he keeps saying
like um i'm considering that was like
last week and now this week he's
announced he's still
he's considering it again he instructed
the uh ecuadorian embassy
the raid on the empirical embassy that's
that's leadership not not what we want
okay not the right leadership right so
he certainly made a decision
paul assange out of the embassy and now
we've yet to see him pardon us
talking about pardoning the guy like
daniel ellsberg
he revealed the war atrocities julian
assange didn't commit any crime
he's just being effectively detained
for a decade nearly it's like eight
years now
and now he's facing charges because they
just don't like that he's effective
he exposed the intelligence agencies
and some of the messed up stuff the us
was doing and it really helped trump
it it showed a lot of trump supporters
exactly what they were doing and why
you know a lot of these arguments
against them uh against like deep state
you know people were were correct and
for a long
time like a good example is sarah palin
she spoke out against wikileaks
wikileaks published her emails sarah
palin just came out defending assange
because what we got out of wikileaks was
good and then you realize
you're gonna get with wikileaks you're
gonna get stuff that probably don't like
you don't want leaked
and you're gonna get stuff they're
probably grateful was leaked we learn
these things from people like assange
but assange isn't even
the leaker or the whistleblower he's the
publisher he's the journalist
and they and they're doing this to him
trump needs to to pardon that guy asap
the concern is if trump pardons him
right now
the uk will find an excuse to keep him
and that trump
his best bet would be to get assange to
the u.s before pardoning him
how don't think it's possible it's like
a secret raid to get him out of there he
already did that
what did he say he raided the ecuadorian
embassy and arrested assange and now
that the british authorities have him
but i mean a raid on the british
authorities
crazy no they're trying to extradite him
but
he has the legal right to block that
tradition and they don't trust the us
government
so they're not going to allow it so i
think trump should just pardon him i
don't think there's any point in waiting
and if
sanji wants to stay in the uk doesn't
want to come here then just pardon him
and be done with it whatever
now how do we deal with the the fact
that people have their rights completely
stomped on in a bunch of these states i
don't know
because do we just sit back as the water
slowly boils when we sit in and we know
for a fact because of supreme court
rulings in like
several states already they are actively
violating constitutional rights of these
people
or do we say something must be done and
trump should invoke the insurrection act
and you know
hypothetically go in and enforce
constitutionality i thought he should
have done it on day two of the riots
but it's like the riots and then there's
the shutdown and it's
like they're two different psychiatrists
listen the the insurrection act has been
invoked
numerous times like couple dozen times
and
the most recent was for riots 1992 l.a
riots
then you also had the baltimore riots
then you had the chicago riots in 1968.
these were nowhere near as crazy as what
we see because of the insurrection act
probably well i'm sorry actually the l.a
riots were pretty
nuts but i think nationwide riots and
then a hundred days in the pacific
northwest they were like trump didn't do
it there were like five days where they
were just watching and then
no one responded federally so then
there's all these other riots started
breaking out you know why it probably
didn't really happen
over the summer and that stuff because i
it's all politics at that point it's
like what move will help him when
reelection will letting them destroy
themselves he doesn't have to worry
about that right now now he doesn't need
to worry or
but at the end of the day we also don't
know what's going on behind the scenes
with this election stuff maybe he knows
some stuff that we don't know
that maybe he knows i'm going to win
this that i like that and the other
thing we don't know that
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you